So describe your first trip.
So the reason why I came to be like Randy you have to find it a bit earlier this is in one thousand nine hundred ninety
nine we have a meeting in mom per year.
This is out of friends and this is a meeting of people dealing with research on longevity.
And they are very attentive to validation which means that if these old person are really so all tense all these are
demographic and so margin it isn't and medical doctor. So at that meeting. You know over ninety nine.
From Sardinia did the presentation
and in this presentation the Explain that in the neuro province where we are either in the neural proteins the number
of made centenarian
and female centenarian is about the same we were really skeptical white because all over the world us five six even ten
times more female centenarian compared to maid centenarian So if you have a place where you have the same number.
It means that probably the male as exaggerate their age.
So they have declared that they are one hundred but they are not one hundred.
So it was clear I remember the coffee break there and during the coffee Reg They say we need to send somebody.